you know when I get down like so my
fourth sip I'm like wait this might be
okay
if I forget my years of training smoke
and then actually a little bit of honey
kind of smell I'm getting sort of like a
soggy wheat cereal note from it not so
much there at all this is like just
barely coffee I think we'll give it two
out of five and violated my tongue like
that in a while and you get get a note
of water from coffee some graham cracker
it's been hiding in the back of your
cupboard for a couple of months you know
all coffee is 99% water I think this may
be 99.9 a 3/4 out of five I think I
might have to brush my teeth for about a
half an hour to get the taste out kind
of alkaline he smells like a dirty
asphalt definitely in your face tongue
is so coated in this thick tar it's like
a stick-to-your-ribs coffee I can really
cook for some bacon and eggs with this
guy I think three and a half out of five
it's halfway tolerable
maybe a little turpentine II kind of
notes maybe a little burnt rubber that's
always nice I think if you drink a lot
of it really fast you can get a little
into melon maybe a side of the road
cantaloupe two and a half out of five
stars maybe a hint of Apple nice and
strong lessen sourness you feel like zip
those sides of your tongue this one is
really not so offensive no still not
very good but head over heels above the
competition you might give it four out
of five stars
don't be fooled I'm not actually excited
to bring us coffee well we're definitely
getting some chemical odors hint of wet
cardboard maybe some potato chip notes
generic Cola perhaps almost gag like
after after all these sips just one star
flat it really was unpleasant
beefy almost mmm this one kind of dances
around on the front of the tongue kind
of get a maybe great Jolly Rancher from
it can even be an African coffee or
maybe a Costa Rican I always know it's
good if your face contracts this one's
more of a breakfast blend and a pretty
dippy this guy is four stars out of five
as well no I'm really getting afraid of
how much I'm starting to like these
coffees ignorance is bliss